before we get started into the video I
want to give a huge shout out to Sir
Shane I think that's how you say it I'm
not really sure how to say it but he
gave me enough dragon bones to get 70
prayer we were complaining about how 70
prayer cost a lot and then he offered to
give me it
and he just believes in the YouTube
channel so shout out to him great guy I
met about a minute later purple fox guy
was doing kbd with and good friend of
mine he decided to give me this so I can
also get my prayer up and he also gave
me five mil so huge shout-outs pearl Fox
and sir Schwinn also I want to tell you
guys my stats for this video I am 96
combat with 72 attack 78 strength 72
defense 88 range 70 prayer 77 magic and
82 hit points alright let's get started
into the video what is up guys in
today's video we are gonna be doing the
loot from one hour of kur asks if you do
not know what crests are they are a
Slayer monster that requires 70 Slayer
so basically the items that you need for
this you need to eat leaf bladed battle
axe and that is the one I recommend you
use you can use any leaf bladed items
such as the sword or the spear or the
broad bolt but I highly recommend you
use the leaf bladed battle axe as it's
way better than the other ones in my
opinion I'm bringing nature runes in
fire rooms so I can hide out the items
that are alcohol I'm bringing one super
strength one super attack the rest is
sharks because I want to stay there for
a while you need a dream and stop for
the teleport option that I am using so
you need to start or complete fairy ring
too and if you do not do that or a fairy
tale too sorry for the fairy ring and if
you do not do that you can easily put
your house in relic ax and then just
teleport there and go to the Slayer cave
and then also I'm bringing a stamina
potion so to get there you're gonna want
to run over here climb under this tunnel
run down here and then you're going to
want to go to configure and then the
place you want to go to is AJR and then
teleport there to the caves and this
puts us right next to the Slayer cave
which is what we're going in and this is
where the relic a teleport would take
you right here where it says from Nick
provenance or
province and now I will speed this up
[Music]
all right I am now here I did have to go
to the bank so I cut that clip I had to
get the reagent bracelet and Berzerker
ring cuz I forgot I was not wearing them
but I will start the timer I'm gonna go
ahead and drink my potions and then I
will go ahead and attack the first kur
asked their level 106 and they have some
very good drips so I'll show you guys
that when I'm back in an hour all right
there is about two minutes left
I'm just hi outing all the items that I
pick up that I can high alq
I've made about over 170 K but there's
about two minutes left I'm gonna go
ahead and speed this up so you guys can
see my last kills
[Music]
alright there is one hour now I will go
ahead and show you guys how much XP I
got I got fifty three point two K
strength XP 17.7 cahit point six v 12.4
k Slayer XP and n 780 magic XP from the
high alkane I picked up all the e one
sec I picked up all the herbs that I
thought were worth picking up I'll go
ahead and put everything in here now to
see how much money we made in an hour I
did get a Snapdragon seed which is very
good get all these items there's a lot
of noted items so keep that in mind
you're gonna get stackables I just
picked up these bones just to add some
and I wrote down the nature rinse down
how many I picked up so 330 is how many
I got
alright so 400 in 67 K or 461 K so
around 470 k is well we made almost 500
K and that's in one hour keep in mind
that if your RNG is better you will get
better items I did come here one time
before and I got a leaf bladed sword and
two mystic rope tops and one task and
that was just over an hour so you can
make more than 500 K in an hour
you can make anywhere from 400 60 K to
about 600 K an hour but I'd say the safe
bet is what I got this time because that
was with no crazy drops I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you guys have any
other ideas for the loot from series go
ahead and leave it in the comments I
like to do loot from something for about
an hour and then show you guys the loot
and I hope you guys are enjoying these
but if you're new to the channel go
ahead and subscribe if you like this boy
and give it a thumbs up and as always
guys thanks for watching stay tuned for
my next video